j'adore la chanson vintage à l'os est à
l'image de ses créateurs deux musiciens
très rétro ou chute du genre à écouter
de grands journaux 1989 sur youtube des
fois j'écoute ce le soit j'en ai plus
grand collectionneur de toulon france au
québec je collectionne des 45 tours
originaux startijenn medelci lisa se bat
il dj horg ont plus de 40 ans ils sont
des rapports et fier de l'être
vintage à l'os est une ode à leur
jeunesse chaque rappeur en cause
ben nous on ne fera pas les jeunes du
ghetto on vient pas du gâteau
non disent on défend les vieux cool puis
on a trouvé un terme
on est déjà là c'était la roue qui
pilent la bourse et nexter si cette
chanson a obtenu plus de 2 millions de
visionnements sur facebook c'est en
partie grâce à carlos ganofsky du défunt
groupe de carlos orchestra
[Musique]
carlos galope ce qui appuie le vidéo
clip original et il a fait plusieurs
ajouts d'image des images d'une autre
époque si vite et quel enfant j'ai
dérapé 101 jeudi je me disais si tout va
bien
lundi matin on a cinquante mille views
puis on va être contente
mais la finale le lundi ce n'est comme
c'était une source de 500 milles lundi
sur le boulevard de la nostalgie
seba et orgue pousseront le concept
encore plus loin avec un album qui
sortira la semaine prochaine sur le
disque grosso modo il parle entre autres
des nordiques et des expos j'allais aux
expos les bleacher à une piasse j'habite
à côté du stade j allais j'allais cruz
et les fidji jamais vraiment suivi le
baseball en tant que tel parce que je
pense que les expos les gens qui aiment
les expos s qui aime le baseball
williams les expos le symbole je suis
musicien complet partir en tournée et
peut-être signera-t-il des autographes
car dj horg est tellement rétro que
plusieurs se souviendront qu'il a joué
dans l'émission ou à ta ta ta race
départ l'année carnets sont morts sanaa
ce mauvais ça m'a tout a souri je
faisais dj pour ce pathétique le lait
petit pagne allez le voir après tant dj
watch ici louis fait depuis mai radio
canada montréal
la casse
[Musique]